hello
[Music]
myself
thank you
yeah
yes yes
ladies and gentlemen welcome to other
people in Austin how you guys feeling
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
we have a great show for you guys this
is just the reminder to please keep
table talk to Abuelo uh please do not
Heckle uh the performers and please uh
avoid looking at your cell phones now
without further Ado please give it up
for your host of the evening hi it's Kim
everybody good bro that's good
thank you guys for coming out tonight to
watch people date this is a show about
dating which is something we've all done
before I actually have a girlfriend now
so you could say I'm an expert
um have you ever had a girlfriend before
I'm not
you guys are [__] [__]
um but yes it's good to be here we have
uh some of the most beautiful people in
Austin and and we got this guy
[Applause]
what happened buddy you uh woke up on
the wrong side of the bed or uh
did someone tell you that mustache was a
good idea
burned
uh so that's kind of what the show's
about it's all about roasting uh people
uh we're gonna have fun tonight if I
could get the buckets up here that'd be
great so we picked names out of a bucket
and they go on a date for 90 seconds and
then we interview them and have a little
comedic repertoire it's the wrong use of
that word
um but yes I have a girlfriend uh key to
having a girlfriend guys is uh always
tell your girlfriend when she looks
tired
girls love that [__]
she's like why'd you tell me that it's
because you literally looked in my face
inside for three seconds 30 seconds
um another thing about girlfriends is
like she gets mad at me when I try to
have sex with her after she just did her
makeup but that's like it's like when
you like the hottest
I'm not supposed to [__] you when you
look hot
oh that's for other people she comes
home at night takes off her makeup now
she's ready for me
put on an old t-shirt that's when Hans
gets his turn
the old vagina
so uh yeah I'm a dating expert I've
dated at least seven women
um but yes we're gonna watch other
people date now like this guy this guy
is gonna be in the new Barbie movie
coming out he uh
he's definitely day raped a couple
chicks
he's uh got no genitals he's smooth down
there he's a beautiful Barbie doll of a
man
are you in the bucket
well May the odds be in your favor fella
you need it
why don't you just go out on Sixth
Street and find someone this guy this
guy actually needs this show
laughs
I'm just kidding uh but we do have a
very funny guest joining us tonight he
this guy is a beautiful soul and he is
hilarious and he's been on kill Tony
before this guy knows
uh very funny guy give it up for Sam
Kuiper
[Applause]
Samuel Kuiper hello everybody how are we
doing
from deep down in Alabama yeah Alabama
yeah how do you like uh Alabama for
dating uh you know
it's easy to go better uh it's better to
go across the hall than across town you
know when your sister's just a couple oh
we're getting started with the incest
Joe the doors are open Sam [__] his
sister which one of these nerds with the
mustache were you roasting earlier is
that all of them oh [__] they're the
same people in different sizes yeah
this is yeah
this table is going to be a problem the
whole night I can tell they're already
three vodka Red Bulls in let's go
they're not gonna remember any of this
tomorrow
oh my God that tone of voice is so
annoying
but luckily we have men in the bucket so
yeah we're gonna get a good man up here
named Tanner for a quick little
interview
Tanner come on up here buddy
but if you're a man you can climb again
if you show these ladies how it's done
yes you sit in one of the two seats
Tanner what brings you out tonight I
just visited my sister she lives out
here so okay so you guys are all out on
the town looking for uh a good time you
guys drinking and doing Molly I just
just drinking yeah just drink it yeah
you don't want to anger the Lord no no
sir the Lord's day no sir all right do
you I bet you guys have crazy plans for
this Memorial Day weekend it seems that
way but no like no you guys I wanted to
go to see Joe Rogan but we ended up with
you
oh yeah I am proud to be a second choice
alternate Joe Rogan
you could have gone to a [__]
wrestling
tournament or I don't know I'm still
trying to figure it out you know well
happy to be here I'm more like a
soy low testosterone Joe Rogan so
nice anyways anything uh you wanna where
are you from where'd you say you're from
uh Albuquerque New Mexico you guys [__]
your sisters there too
yeah
Sam loves a good sister I'm getting all
horned up talking about black ladies
although he's into that too
uh which one is your sister
this the loud one the loud one is that
your birthday or are you just always
this annoying
[Applause]
I'm sorry I cut a woman off
oh congratulations and how do you guys
know who's who how do you know all your
friends over there
are you in a sorority you go to UTA
I don't know what the [__] you're
talking about then you got sisters
somehow are you in a Mormon family
okay uh well you guys are all ethnically
uh the same except for one Mexican lady
did she do all the cleaning up she uh
dumps all the Red Bull cans out into the
recycling
all right they don't listen very well uh
what was Tanner so uh what's what's been
your favorite part of hanging out with
uh with your group that you found this
weekend
we floated the river yesterday like that
was nice yeah I floated I feel like you
always flat the river you live on the
river I'm a river guy River Rat
are there uh okay cheer for that for
some reason
do you are there a lot of rivers in ABQ
no no Rivers we're pretty dry over I
mean we have the Rio Grande but it's
[__] empty right now so what happened
no water yeah yeah just no water
well it's uh not the only thing dry
around you I'm talking about your
sister's [__]
she has to hang around with your ass
trying to get some dick on 6th Street
you say she's very wet is that what you
just said wow we're talking about incest
here and you're over here encouraging it
I love it so uh are you in uh Ken doll
over here going out on the town just
tearing it up
no he was in my uh so I went to
University Utah
and he was in my fraternity yeah he he
was in my fraternity obviously cool guy
Tanner are you single
I am not single oh so you're just
breaking hearts out here you're just a
[__] that's my girlfriend right here oh
should I try that one
they all look the same to me yeah
no one wants to claim it did you sign up
too
yes oh yeah that's very feminist of you
are you guys open well I just heard that
you guys have trouble getting girls to
come up here doing this what the [__]
what does that have to do with you bring
a lot of girls oh okay hell yeah well
thank you for bringing the most didn't
know where you're going loudest girls
ever
I'm trying to put it nicely because I
don't want them to be mad at me
we need you
there's plenty of men there's not enough
women oh we got a female coming up here
by the name of morgie with a heart over
the eye morgie
Morgan he's going on a date
with the sorority girl's brother who's
in a fraternity yeah
here she comes and they're gonna go on a
date for 90 seconds give it up for
Morgan
90 seconds starting now hi hi Tanner yep
how are you doing I'm Buzz drunk but I'm
getting through okay yeah period today
okay
um so fraternity boy I was did you do
any homoerotic things when you are in
the fraternity
I mean yeah kiss your kids
no definitely not oh my god do you not
know what homoerotic means no I do I
went to University Utah though so we
were surrounded with like a bunch are
you a Mormon no I'm not why not
my life you don't like what's his name
Joseph Smith
Joseph yeah Joseph Smith
yep yeah he was he was a dog he was a
guy a dog oh
oh that was rad [__] yeah yeah I like to
get really high and drive around like I
like to smoke weed too yeah yeah
yeah
yeah well what do you like on your pizza
what do I like on my pizza
um okay so I work at a pizza place so
like obviously if I eat a ton of pizza
I'll get fat so you don't eat pizza oh
no I eat a nice cheese pizza keep it
plain and simple skinny slate you know
Ranch skinny Ranch jalapeno Ranch baby
come on I don't like spice uh I can tell
chocolate it's okay it's okay male boy
oh
all right I know I'm playing she's nice
yeah no I'm gonna make him feel guilty a
little bit and time give it up for
Tanner and morgie
thank you hello
they can say that to each other Mayo boy
because they're
that's how white people talk to each
other
I'm Mexican okay Brown oh yeah
so a Mexican no but I could if there was
a race war no choose a side
what side would you choose yeah you
would be able to choose a side until you
started giggling with your Stoner laugh
and they'll be like
this guy's definitely white
yeah give him a skateboard if he can do
an Ollie he's white I'm gonna Escape
first try I could definitely skateboard
morgie have you ever dated a skateboard
guy before
yeah skaters
have you ever had a skater guy do a nose
grind in your [__] uh yeah multiple
multiple times
hyena for that joke what oh you get uh
getting e now in public by skater
period oh yeah I know
what can I say guys look like you
pledged at the same sorority
I just called you a woman
product things no I didn't know you
literally
you should you should I didn't know what
the word it's okay to not know it
I did it at the time now so what did you
learn in college
not much I mean it's College bro you
just drink the snowboarded a lot you
know but anyway like snowboarding like
yeah
you really
really up not that type of slope
Morgan you were bragging about being
skinny uh do you think that's like cool
or like do you think you're fat shaming
some people
I feel like you got nasty [__] no
comments whoa
you eat cheese pizza and jalapeno Ranch
toilets beware
how do you all the prettiest girls have
the stinkiest shits yeah they gotta get
all that [__] out hey I'm healthy I eat
vegetables okay
good for you I don't actually eat
vegetables I'm lying we got Tanner a guy
that uh lived in Utah but is not Mormon
what you hated [__] that much
what's the gayest thing you've done in
your life [__]
[__] dug myself in a hole here now I
don't know what to say have you ever
eaten the cracker
and not talking about your friends I
just feel like I should say no from now
on like deny deny deny no no no say no
to the Gay Thoughts dude say no
they're not real Sam if you had to guess
what the gas thing Tanner has done is
what do you think that this guy has done
how far do you think he went I think
he's definitely stuck his thumb up one
of his pledge Brothers
it's not even gay that's just strength
hey future rap that [__] dude the future
did it it's not gay
Morgan has definitely done gay [__] so
I'm not even gonna ask she's definitely
ladies John if you know what I mean
uh Morgan what's like uh your favorite
thing about women versus men
um okay eating [__] is so much better
than sucking dick hell yeah lady yeah
[Music]
is there a Texas Sorority Girl is that
true
that's what you say yes
Tanner what uh what what uh how did you
meet your girlfriend
um I met her when I moved back home
after college and you're like Hey
sisters are pretty close now
dude this will all go away if you just
tell us what homo [__] you did
no then you're a sister [__] all right
so did you guys know each other in high
school or college we didn't no you just
happened to be in the same city yeah I
mean it's a small City but yeah we were
what is your pickup line
what was my pickup line
hey drink this
[Laughter]
your sister likes that she knows too
much about you does this smell like
chloroform
how many packs of cigarettes you smoke
today [__]
yeah this is what happens after uh
Memorial Day weekend on 6th Street
okay
you're annoying uh
Morgan
what's up hello what advice would you uh
give to the ladies tonight
um if he doesn't eat your [__] you find
a new one
oh yeah I think everyone's
it's 2023 I think we've moved to the
butthole now oh that's the elementary
[__] do you eat your girlfriend's
butthole once uh yes is she getting that
Royal Treatment that royal flush
I'll do whatever she asked me to do
I love my girlfriend don't she ask you
to eat her ass
actually has she asked you to eat her up
has she asked me um she's a lady I would
never ask that of her but Morgan have
you ever eaten someone's ass before I
have not wait actually no I've been in a
girl's ass before but I've been like
different than a man's ass man I don't
know well it's like you eat [__] and
like the [__] is just like right
there it just happens less exfoliation
of the face when you're eating a woman
out
um what anyways
Tanner uh what's your what's your uh
what's your go-to move in the bedroom I
bet you're uh pretty good with your
tongue if you know what I mean
I'm pretty uh just you know
yeah you're a male boy oh just vanilla
forward straight forward you know
straight to the point on some HBO man
lay in prayer you do a little soaking in
your time in Utah some HBO Max on and
try to figure it out you know okay uh no
wonder your girlfriends
so uh loud right now
because she's not getting it in the
bedroom Tanner is a bad way uh Morgan
how would you excite
she's very defensive she's very
defensive
[Applause]
Tanner have you ever tried to convince
her to get a boob job oh we're working
on it working on it hello
topic organization
very loyal girlfriend you have she gets
up in the middle and of a show and just
starts preaching about how good your
dick is yep
great dick great dick
how does that feel to know your brother
is a big dick
what
definitely some people are gonna jerk
off to this later
Morgan uh yeah how would you uh
recommend Tanner spice up his love life
um
let her put her finger in your butt
okay well Tanner is in a relationship no
like she needs to put her finger in his
butt
I would do like just like just a
straight middle one no yeah yeah dude
that was so surprising when it happens
so they love it
stick your finger up guys butts so
[__] go crazy it's insane it's funny
you're just molesting men's butts yeah
dude I'm praying on guys booty holes
beware
yeah no there's a whole system
[Laughter]
[Music]
how do you work your way up to a finger
in the butt um so you start with the
balls and you just like I swear to God
you just move your hand closer to the
butthole they will not fight it they'll
be like spreading their cheeks I'm like
they want it bro and they're just like
and like literally they'll be like you
like it you like it before yeah yeah no
you got it you gotta Loop it up Loop it
up for sure yeah come on yeah it's a
finger of the butt you gotta be gentle
come on I don't know I don't know how
good the sex is with your girl he's just
[__] going in hard I obviously got
a little bit put a finger in my butt
that's what you think that's what you're
saying now thank you that's what you're
saying now but she's inching towards
your butthole when y'all [__] or
something I'm telling you will not be
saying no it never happens it's never
happened are you taking notes even when
men say no they don't mean it oh no
Morgan uh
that's interesting you just uh work your
way to the butt
um yeah what's uh what's the craziest
thing you got a man to do for you
um I had this one guy get my initials
tattooed on him when he was in jail
like a prison tattoo what are your
initials m-a
are you sure he wasn't just from
Massachusetts mom
how long was he in jail for was he like
a life sentence no no it's like a couple
months thing I don't know he like
stopped talking to me after that yeah
clearly yeah men do be like that when
they get out of jail I know
yeah no he found a nice Korean
girlfriend hell yeah [__] my people
dude my people [__] your people
he was Mexican as well so okay
well I feel like we're [__] you guys
more financially so
I don't know what
[Music]
okay thank you Morgan for being on the
show
yeah yeah
Morgan and Tanner
[Applause]
thank you Tanner
if there's an actual single guy here and
a girl drops the ball we'll definitely
get you back up here so you can actually
find a mate that's not taken but uh
coming up here we got Chloe Chloe Chloe
Chloe
there's stairs to the right Chloe if you
want to if you want to take it the easy
way all right
any come up music for a Chloe is he even
there we're not even there
Nick is jerking off in the bathroom
what's up Chloe Chloe she provides her
own music yeah
all right everyone give it up for Chloe
it's your own damn friend give it up for
her
[Applause]
Chloe so which which uh member of sex in
the city are you in your group of
friends are you oh my god Samantha hell
yeah what what's the most Samantha thing
about you
well
should get around a lot
my sky had sex with him
he said he's having a baby so I'm pretty
dry in that department right now so
there's any hot guys in the crowd Chloe
that's what this whole show is about
we're gonna get a guy for you you don't
have to ask you had sex with him on
Mother's Day that was the last time you
had sex no
no we have it day
how long it's been okay I thought you
were like last time we had sex Mother's
Day 2022. announce Mother's Day an
ultrasound so Chloe why the dry spell me
why the dry spell I think I'm being a
lady you're taking care of yourself what
have you been doing this whole time not
getting dick
foreign
oh you're gonna talk okay are you uh
have you ever heard your parents [__]
no my mom's divorced but actually that's
a great reason to hear that my parents
got divorced when I was seven and then
my freshman no senior year of high
school they started [__] again and my
mom told me that my dad was big into sex
toys so how does that make you feel is
this why you've been having a dry spell
you've been thinking about that maybe it
traumatized me
well your answers are very long which is
good I
yeah I love it you know we're not we're
not currently doing the date portion but
you're already in the zone your sex life
yeah in fact I would love to hear about
yourself to kill Tony
[Music]
Chloe let's open the floor Chloe why
don't we get a date for you so you can
stop being so horny on stage Jesus
hey
you know what you know what the
situation requires it's time for a
special guest
of the show a very funny guy a very Live
Wire are you ready Chloe for cam
Patterson
[Applause]
hi nice to meet you nice to meet you you
like black guys
terrifically I'm gonna be honest you're
gonna be gonna say some racist [__] no
no you don't like [__] Club
yeah [__] with a black guy before the
day started let's start today I've only
[__] half but he had a big dick and it
was so big I'm a fool I'm all the way up
I don't know if I can handle you gotta
get your titties something on
they're out there yeah I know
yeah I'm about to pop one please please
please so contain yourself it's hard
it's a tough thing to do you are you
very beautiful I like your face thank
you all you got a nice face you know I'm
saying
hell yeah
your friend get it yeah
she understand yeah they all do I'll do
it I'm 22. almost 23. give me a couple
months yeah yeah that's perfect for you
I'm 24.
I
you want to do
what you want to do I want to be rich
Let's Do It
you ever saw crap before
you can make a lot of money I'm
desperate we can make a lot of money
people make sell a crack Club
we'll be rich tomorrow I'll be on the
corner yeah you'll be on the other block
if I got that [__] yeah yeah that's
great hey [__] all the days [__] I found
my little trap Queen is over [__] [__]
we've done it and time give it up for a
cam Patterson and Chloe
Chloe's about to be on the Real
Housewives of Compton
Chloe when's the last time you've been
shot at
it it's been a while I won't get to a
gun baby it's great we'll get to a nice
little 22.
yeah Gloria put that mic right by your
mouth when you're talking act like it's
Cam's dick
[Music]
practicing I like Chloe dog do we like
it
cam yeah you're very uh smooth guy uh
what's uh what's your history been like
with white women oh they only suck my
dick before I never fought one
I have TMJ
what that mean what I mean
lockjaw
yeah
it was like y'all built in with dick
sucking abilities it's like yeah that
sounds awesome like a pitbull your job I
don't suck dick oh you don't suck dick
TMJ because you got a lot though no I
really don't but you know who does Tara
wow she's holding on her friends now oh
Taya you suck dick no no and you know
her boyfriend is Kim girl and TMJ
doesn't affect their relationships
you're not getting [__] on the reg
okay dog what a gay man this guy is
gay this is my only day to see a guy
that looks like this that's why he's so
far away from her that's crazy
suck my dick I hate this old I don't
like this [__] this is horrible Chloe
why are you revealing personal
information about your friends love it
take the spotlight off of me Chloe
what's the most embarrassing thing about
yourself huh what's the most
embarrassing thing about yourself oh God
there's probably so [__] much
I don't know
anything that happens I don't know let's
come back around let's go what happened
last time eight months ago when you had
sex for the last time actually I started
my period and he goes you're bleeding
and I'm like what do you mean I'm
bleeding and it got really scary and we
had to go upstairs to her apartment
right there and we'd go up there and I
can't you guys are all like 19.
she's nowhere
Now where's Emily she's under the
blankets completely he's sitting
straight up from your bloody [__] he's
been doing some things as well
I don't know where the [__] the story
went what's going on I think she was
sucking somebody's dick suicide and she
walked in they all [__] okay
there's always a lot going on yeah
I can dance sexism
I can pretend to dance You Can Dance
[__] how long I know that you want to
dance for us
I was so [__] up let's go baby yeah
yeah
yeah come on right yeah okay good job
Chloe
oh Cam's getting involved now
[Applause]
[Music]
he's gonna show it on a twerk
take a picture and send it to her dad
[Music]
that was interracial Harmony
we saw black people and white people
coming together
I'm not talking about
I'm talking about the sex kind of come
[Music]
Chloe how did that make you feel or did
you express yourself tonight oh my God I
loved it what did we think am I good
because they were [__] on me honest
reviews honest reviews pretty typical
it's pretty typical for a white girl you
know but your dance skills are like four
four out of ten but yeah
Chloe sit down don't sit down
I like it come on I just learned that
right here I love it I love it cam what
would you teach Chloe to improve her
dancing oh how to clap her ass cause she
got a lot of ass so she gotta learn how
to shake it off a lot it's decent I got
more up here no it's certified
compliment from a black dude they don't
lie about this [__] yeah I'm an
assologist I know ass for real all right
well we'll take lessons after this yeah
careful
I know we had a oh my God contemplation
overwhelming so Chloe uh what's your
favorite thing about dating white people
okay just talking about this because I
recently just gone into this Jewish guy
but I realized most of them are
uncircumcised and I don't know if I want
to know how does it make you feel when
you pull down a dude's pants and it's
uncircumcised I mean not bad it doesn't
make me feel bad I can deal with
anything
right
and I learned most Jewish people have a
lot of money
bye you learned that I thought that was
you don't know man we gonna sell
Kevin you don't need money but my mom
just told me that I think my mom really
wants me to go for him
Chloe uh he's a single mom Chloe how
would you sell crack on the streets of
Compton oh my God it just stay on the
[__] Corner they'd be coming to me
yeah but not for crack yeah
and I'd wear half this I'd wear half
this
oh no this we we date we married now who
are you this is my wife
[__] you talking about
I love you [__]
I love you
I ain't never gonna [__] with you
[Music]
my cinnamon apple baby I love you [__]
recently got married to Chloe so he's
gonna be leaving Chloe any minute now
as soon as she gets pregnant cam is out
of there oh God not the kids
not the kids I'll come back when he go
to the lead dude
is it gonna be good at football
I'm not very athletic I am
[Applause]
I'm five four our kids are not athletic
they'll be good at badminton they're
gonna be boxers yeah they'll be good at
Asian sports ping pong hey let me ask
you because you like getting your ass
ate never have hell yeah but I'm not I'm
not opposed hell yeah
hell yeah that makes something happen
all right I like this I like Chloe
though
hell y'all like Chloe a lot Chloe uh how
did how does how do you think your
parents would take it if you brought cam
home
wouldn't it be happy my mom would be
cool hell yeah cause your mom knows
she's probably dated a black guy or two
in her past I think honestly my mom
hasn't been digged down in a [__]
while
a while mother like daughter oh truly
truly not [__]
truly please think out loud more please
but my mom does like butt stuff and I've
heard my dad who was opposed to the
finger in the ass it was you my father
he loves it up the ass a thumb I've
heard
well it sounds like you guys gonna have
gay Sons
just sounds like my parents
followed it
there's no problem yeah yeah yes I love
gay people no problem with the thumb
yeah give it up for Cam he's not
homophobic
and Chloe damn
keeping it real
with Cam Patterson
[Music]
okay co-host Sam is getting his beak wet
on the show
one of the perks of the job
huh
Sam have you ever uh hooked up with
anyone after the show not right after
not immediately after oh okay
he's just laying pray and wait you're
more of a I had a girl I used to be on
hinge I had this girl hit me up one time
uh and she was like I saw you at the
other people's show and I was like oh
[__] it was
the Lord's day after all we got Cody
coming up
come on up Cody what's up Cody
is a long time member of the other
people dating scene Cody when's the last
time you up like a month ago a couple
months right right yeah you still
beekeeping yes I was beekeeping today
wow a real life beekeeper he can provide
you food and shelter yes
do you know how to build a shelter I
know how to build many shelters I have
the Wilderness survival mirror badge
yeah and a bandana to the match
did they give you that bandana when you
uh lose your virginity no no they take
it away when you lose it
he's a virgin sorry
Cody how's uh the dating scene been have
you ever gotten uh hooked up with any
hippie chicks that also wear bandanas
that also work at what have you ever
hooked up with hippie chicks that also
wear bandanas no not that we're bandanas
well you would be perfect for them
because you guys could both braid each
other's hairs
sure Cody uh what's your favorite thing
about uh
being a hippie kind of looking guy
uh probably the weed
oh yeah what about it you smoke it or
no I just like to buy it and look at it
hey he's uh you do that the bud
crystals on it
Cuddy so uh what do you look for in a
woman what's your ideal woman
someone probably with a career or at
least an idea and a career in mind
okay so you're looking for someone that
can function in the real world yes it's
pretty low bar would you call what's
your career
what's your career uh my career uh I
work for a video game company whoa he
works in Tech and he's has a hobby
and they're different
is there not a lot of female co-workers
that's your place it's definitely like a
70 30 split it's majority mail have you
ever had a finger in your butt yes from
a male co-worker or Not A co-worker no
game testing no joysticks up there yeah
[__]
[Music]
and test out the rumble pack
it's always Nintendo with the joy-con
that's always makes you go away with
joy-con
Cody is getting deep
um yeah have you ever met a girl that
was into like video games and like nerdy
[__] because I feel like yes but it's
always been someone who's been already
in a relationship
ah
and that's a no-go for you you're a
respectful man I am yes okay well
hopefully your date that we pick is
single hopefully we're gonna get a woman
up here
hopefully hopefully hopefully it's not
one probably a lot of things hopefully
you should like make virgins hopefully
which would be great too we got Emily
Emily
Emily Emily
bro come on up your friends have added
you you've been outed Emily come on
Emily Warriors
or commitment
we do know she's the only girl in the
group that gives blow jobs
[Laughter]
put that jaw to work okay
Emily going on a date with Cody starting
now hello Emily hello how are you good
scared I'm scared yeah why I don't like
talking about large crowds oh okay so
you just pretend there's a wall there
that's the fourth wall okay fair enough
I don't know what that means
all right well I just ignore the people
pretend they're not there or they're
just the voices in your head well see
you broke the rule already okay sorry
first of all uh so you're with all of
these people did you graduate recently
I haven't graduated yet no okay
yeah that's not talking about it okay
let's not talk about that that's fine
we're in the work so bad I went to
Community College for six and a half
years and then I landed my job and the
first thing I was told was what college
is for the birds [__] that okay if
you're telling me that and you're my
boss
I love an uneducated men no I wouldn't
say I'm uneducated but I didn't graduate
perfect
um so do you have any hobbies
um no no Hobbies I like to sleep I need
to sleep okay I smoke away on occasion
okay there we go that that can count as
a hobby I make wine for a living okay
that's pretty legit tell me about making
wine nothing
I'm not very good at it I lied a lot on
my resume I just kind of show up and do
whatever I'm told I crash the forklift
on Thursday
oh and time good for wine
sorry to interrupt this riveting base
but uh I had to learn more about coding
community college career we're gonna
interview
six and a half years it's a long time to
be I didn't know what I wanted to do a
loser oh
ouch I feel it as financially
responsible it was very Financial you
have a great job now you're beekeeping
did you learn that in community college
or no
what Emily is that true
let's go
have you ever made uh
keeping have you ever made
have you ever made wine from honey
maybe you guys could collaborate I've
done something of the sorts because I
think it's called Mead yeah they call it
that but apparently it's called flower
wine now we don't know
wow sounds like you know though
some weird anti-noredic stuff going on
what Meads Nordic beverage shut up Cody
so
um
you like beekeeping what do you like
about beekeeping is it a real hobby
interest or is it just like you saw a
YouTube video once I just think they're
cute
babies
yeah no I think bees are cute you like
them you like men in Bee suits yeah like
zipping it off and kissing through the
mesh oh yeah I have a bee suit a little
flutter oh yeah
yeah you can't give [__] and Bee
suits oh you can
whoa
how did you discover this hole
um too many questions okay five minutes
are up I thought uh you have a bad sense
of time
yeah that's good for you Cody she's
gonna be like wow you lasted for hours
foreign
she doesn't get jokes where are you from
where am I from yeah where are you from
South Korea your turn I'm from San
Antonio okay yeah that explains that
before that what do you mean I mean
where where in Latin America are you
from or India where's Latin America
God damn it you're dumb no I'm kidding
do you make wine or do you just drink it
all
give and take give and take that's what
jobs are about I suppose so Emily uh are
you single yes wow a single person for
once on the show okay thank you hi guys
okay Emily what uh what what made you
single are you just out here playing the
field just breaking hearts clearly I
can't hold the conversation so that's
one part well
I'm working out but you can suck a dick
we found out yeah we don't need it that
is true that's good that's 50 it's good
thanks
is there is there anything embarrassing
about Chloe that you like to reveal
right now
oh really
two words tennis player no tennis player
one time I met her wait what's what
state was that was that Oklahoma or
Arkansas
Norman Oklahoma and I flew out to go
meet them for a football game yeah
she banged uh he said he was from France
and he played on the tennis team I don't
think he would even go to this here's
the janitor
I don't even think he went to the school
I looked him up his name did not pop up
she banged him in the [__] uh
bathroom uh what was it called like the
country stay in
Homewood Suites oh God and they closed
on the bathroom for the rest of the week
oh God
some of that eight months of not having
sex [__] all over the place this was a
Mexican dude pretending to do a French
accent
it's probably a ping pong player from
Quebec yeah he did not pop up on the
roster and I looked him up how
embarrassing you had sex with someone
poor
Cody is there anything embarrassing in
your sex life that you would like to
reveal
that I haven't already
well we've learned a couple things but
is there anything else that stands out
to you
um
no your parents ever caught you jerking
off
once yeah I feel like that is true
jerking off into your handkerchief
bandana what happened did you think they
weren't home and then like Mom forgot
something and she came back in or
you're like spread eagle on the couch
it was quite a while ago I don't
remember but that's probably the gist of
it it's not etched into your memory
you're just like I remember Mom walking
in I don't know
30 minutes I only remember the instance
of oh [__] there's mom yeah
and then you came
yeah the excitement it's a little bit of
that same Kuiper in you
so that's a that's an incest joke yeah
okay yeah
your mom walked in and you're
masturbating and it didn't even leave a
leave a memory for you no left distinct
memory I had to explain to her because
she wouldn't leave until I explained to
her what I was doing well she [__]
knew was your mom oh yeah she knew yeah
what'd you tell her I had to tell her I
was masturbating like what are you doing
I used that word what are you doing
that's what your dad does yeah
super sleeping what were you watching or
thinking are you thinking in there about
something or are you like I do not
remember whatever Twilight
you know the time of day
Emily have you ever walked in on
somebody jerking it
yeah who was it and why was why were you
hanging out with Louis CK
too many questions
let's just say I have too many white
friends you was that a thing about white
dude I don't take off all the time
oh yeah how do you think they make that
Mayo Mayo boy
okay you don't commit to your stories
you like say the subject and you're like
Fizzles out
you're high right now for sure huh no
I'm not oh you're normally like this
that's worse
I didn't have a backup I thought I
thought I was confident
so Cody where would you take uh the
beautiful Emily on a date
uh do you like thrifting
you like sucking dick through a bee suit
[Laughter]
okay yeah
a couple of holes that we can check out
if you'd like to check out some Thrift
balls moth
I think they're called I think they're
called Outlets
Emily is afraid for some reason probably
because there's a lot of white dudes
jerking off in there
it's bigger than a store
okay fair enough sure yeah have you ever
been to a mall before he can show you
the world
let me show you the white world of malls
what would you do thanks for laughing
what would you uh
what would you do in a mall with Emily
I usually just look at [__] and talk
about it it's a good conduit for
conversation you gotta make it more
exciting than that like take mushrooms
or something oh well okay if we're
skipping to like date two then yeah we
do the same thing but this time on
mushrooms and it's a whole different
experience yeah one's boring well you
gotta have the Baseline to know how
boring it is to really realize you're
gonna set out with a boring day just so
she knows how exciting the other dates
are well I gotta know stick around
that's not how you do it though
I want a real one well we're trying to
help but uh
well Emily I hope you gain more energy
throughout the day maybe a couple more
vodka Red Bulls
yeah what happens when you smoke do you
what happens when you how are you when
you smoke what do you mean when you get
high when I get high how do you act
anything like that you put your purse
get out of my lawn bro it's an accent
but she's high it's our cookout bro cook
out what does that even mean
okay well hopefully your brothers don't
come up and shoot this place up
what is that called the low rider what
have you ever ridden in a low rider
before a low rider
um
right now we're all having fun see
they're making fun of me I'm making fun
of you for not self-incriminating my
family thank you
what's your best roast joke for Emily
right now
I don't think I know a lot about her to
roaster but I could say she seems vapid
but that just wow
Cody
come on you're still in the game man I
don't even know what that word means
exactly
he said you're very rapid rappy though
vapid okay give it up Emily Jesus Christ
yeah Cody you don't double down on
things like that right that was only 30
Bandana's fault
we got Liz a woman is that you you what
was that
is Liz one of your friends
Liz Liz you back there
what up Liz
are you Liz
did you sign up come on okay yeah
Tanner's girlfriend it's Liz she's in a
relationship
[Music]
give it up for Liz everybody
thank you
Liz that's all you get yeah you've been
yelling the entire show that's so lame
how about that
Liz how did you uh meet Tanner what's
the story behind that honestly it's
pretty boring mutual friends mutual
friends nice you guys were in one of
these giant frat sorority groups herds I
was not in a sorority but you just
partied at fraternities
you're acting like you're in a police
interrogation I
can't say I kind of feel like I am okay
well you're not
we're just trying to find the perfect
guy for you that's not Tanner yeah
what do you uh what do you like about
Tanner what's your favorite thing that
he does
well I don't want to get too personal
just say something like washing the
dishes or
you know making you wear a burqa he owns
a house he owns a house
how old are you Tanner
oh you're way too young to own a house
he's definitely got rich parents to the
mobile house
what uh what if what do you like to do
in a house all all with Tanner do you
guys play the music loud or do drugs
all of the above have you ever been in
an exam all of the above
exam fun I think that was option D right
option D all of the above option dick
yeah you're getting [__] down in a
house with Tanner how long have you and
Tanner been together
well I'm asking you
you say and then how long do his exes
yeah
I'd say about two years okay wow Tanner
is that just yes or no okay he's lying
thanks for the support
okay so uh before you were dating Tanner
what kind of dates were you looking for
uh
you're acting like we're at church and
this is a confession how old are you
first
how old do I look well 22. uh just
guessing 22. that's what someone said
they were 47. 27 37. because it's old as
[__] all right all right the stage is
set for a white shining armor
a guy with a fan up here okay I'm 25
going on 27. she really wanted to answer
that
that's cool joke there so two years I
don't know Drew Santana Drew
Drew Drew
santiana
the [__] Drew is that you here he comes
from the back
it's Drew
he's got a very cool look about him he
looks like he plays music on E6 yeah
hello Drew I love the fanny pack
I have a fanny pack but I left it at
home
I I wasn't paying attention to what you
were saying I just said I love your
fanny pack oh I heard that
oh
good luck yes yes I'm scared good luck
thank you
uh
um
I I was jokingly thinking if you called
my name up that I would sneak out the
back but
I committed to it
[Music]
uh
this is normally how it goes shake hands
that's a good starting point
uh
I like your skinny jeans and I like your
pendant that you're wearing
um
[Music]
I wasn't prepared for this I didn't know
what to expect
um
just say I like your I like your
flip-flops
um uh yes
uh women intimidate me uh you you uh
intimidate me but at times
give it up for Drew Santana Drew what
what kind of [__] are you drew
uh you're one of them that's for sure
Drew is the uh
uh is the autistic Edward Cullen yeah
for sure it's low-hanging fruit he's a
member of the uh vampire family that was
too autistic
he's definitely schizophrenic look your
whole vibe just changed you're like what
personality is this dude
I will roundhouse kick you okay if you
[__] I'm just kidding I I don't I
don't know if I'm too high or not high
enough yeah but we'll see you said you
wish you snucked out the back I wish the
same thing yeah
[Applause]
weird
really weird way to [__] up a date oh
yeah really with uh good looks like you
all you have to do is act like a SIMS
character yes no maybe she started with
a compliment you're like
have you ever uh gotten laid before
it's not that bad I swear who do you
normally go for what kind of people do
you normally like to have sex with
ironically
uh crazy women that's the ones that talk
to me that's usually how it goes I'm
kind of crazy oh God yeah this guy's
like the Joker if he found whippets
you're into crazy women or men
uh it's it's been a while odds it's been
a while since
what's your story for real dude are you
a comic or something yeah I I've been
here 20 days now and I came here for the
comedy scene and I've just been doing uh
as many open mics as possible hell yeah
is this your style of Comedy uh
uncomfortable [__]
it normally does so how does your opener
usually work where you just giggle
nervously uh yeah it's uh [__] it's
low hanging fruit to say I look scary
and gay
well I'm scared and I'm convinced you're
gay
good luck
[Music]
Liz are you glad you're with Tanner now
this is what's out there
this guy definitely doesn't have a house
where are you living right now what kind
of van
uh yes thank you yes
yes now I feel bad dude I feel like I
hurt your feelings
I'm sorry where do you live
uh I uh yes I do I do live in my van I
came here oh yeah
um
so uh how do you like living in a van in
Austin it's a little hot
uh yes it's hot
um your car is set to preheat
uh I pay for a gym that doesn't have
hobos around it like you wherever you go
there's the hobo the calls are coming
from within the house
you sound like you'd be really good at
delivering sad news
Drew I want you to deliver the sad news
to Liz right here that Tanner has
unfortunately died and you're her new
boyfriend
action
I I uh
uh
Tanner is uh he has
um [__] died
um so yeah I'd imagine that would make
you pretty lonely I I'm also lonely
um
and scene wow that was a lot creepier
than I thought it'd be for some reason
I don't know what I expected he's saying
your fanny pack
marijuana
lots of marijuana all of the marijuana
that's apparently the same drug that
Emily took tonight
you're basically the male version of
Emily uh
yeah what would that dative look like
it's a lot better when Emily is being
Emily when a guy with a dick is being
weird and low energy it's kind of scary
I am I I don't sleep well what would you
say to Emily to maybe rescue her from
becoming drugged out
it's an intervention shut up
thank you
shut the [__] up
I'm actually dying inside right now this
is the most anxious that I got past this
but uh wow are you a comedian you said
uh I I'm I'm trying to be and you're
nervous on stage uh oh yeah I thought it
worked past it uh but this is uh very
intimidating oh okay that's nice he's
got a vulnerable side Liz what would you
say to make him feel better
what's your coping technique
for stage fright
you're a good looking dude man you
should be so nervous I don't know
you should be nervous you [__] it up
in the beginning
well that's Personality yeah you're
starting off with a win though she came
she complimented you she was like I love
your fanny pack and you're like I'm gay
[Music]
give us your best shot this is your
moment
I'd rather not
this is uh I wasn't um of all of all the
ones I was hoping not to get called up
for should we get another day no they
did not have to come up Drew uh
called up with
she's not here
what was she liking my best shot
Tanner's a lucky man
Drew what do you usually say on dates
like at you laid
they usually say hi first that's not a
joke
so you're in your uh school for the
definitely abled and a girl come says hi
to you
and then where does it go you guys play
with Play-Doh together
thank you very much
autistic
I'm sorry
so what's the most comfortable you've
ever felt before when uh
um not right [__] now okay probably
why you're nervous because you can't
stop thinking about
the bad stuff think about like uh
something good that happened to you
what's something that you're proud of
you ever had a finger up your butt I
mean I I no okay have you ever stuck it
for your finger up a butt yes your own
butt
you say you're weird
I don't know where to go with you dude
I'll be honest
wow Drew
um very interesting
uh choices you made up here tonight
uh What uh what really gets you going
what what excites you
um heroin
Twilight
trains
this is this is uh this is this is what
happens
um I actually become [__] around
women that talk to me women please
shut up
this guy's autistic
you have some respect you're in Austin
these are the only men that are out here
okay they all work in Tech they're all
like this you gotta learn
so you can take his money
I don't I don't work in Tech I don't
have any money I know I'm just a shitty
guys like autistic comment uh yeah
you're like a guy that works in Tech but
without any of the money
um Liz so uh how how many people have
you dated before I mean don't tell me
that but like what kind of people have
you dated before Tanner do you usually
go for like sad emo dudes or like
Tanner no one better
no one better than Tanner no one better
so that's your type is like a guy with a
house
I think you set me up for failure here
are you up for failure
Liz uh so that's uh you're you're kind
of with Tanner now that's cool what uh
what do you like about being in a
relationship
I think that's pretty much uh constant
in every woman's life whether they're in
a relationship or not
wow I mean I mean we don't want to be
oh my God I can't
decide who's more autistic now yeah
do you what did you grow up in a church
or something
I did not no okay you just look Mormon
not Mommy
well uh you know you guys are have great
skin both of you
you look like you only do butt stuff
because you're saving yourself for
marriage for cheese Jesus yeah
well Liz thank you for coming up here
please give our compliments to Tanner
yeah
thank you thank you thank you
Drew thank you so much for coming up
here please anybody on the way out it's
all fun and games cheer up you're a good
looking dude
[Applause]
we got time for one more couple
we're gonna get a man named Dylan
rasuchi up on stage
foreign
how have you been so far
pretty good
anything going on in your dating life no
girls shut the [__] up please yeah they
really haven't stopped seriously shut up
vapid was the perfect word dude I don't
mean to uh be sexist but uh most of you
are girls
she's doing great security feel like the
girl that can't give a [__]
because she's quiet yeah her mouth's too
small I guess yeah have you ever been
with a girl that uh can't give you a
[__]
can't yeah
uh yeah kind of yeah it's like all teeth
I had to stop her
so you gotta date him old
go to something I think you
huh he's on something yeah maybe yeah
the best blow job I got was from a woman
was older
[Music]
not like super old
yeah
yeah she was like four and a half years
older
whoa dude you're a you're a cougar
Chaser oh yeah Dylan uh have you have
you gotten better at eating [__] since
you've been
been aging
I mean I guess yeah more experience you
know how do you how do you do it
differently now than you did in the past
well I haven't done I don't know you
just you gotta just do you gotta just
figure it out I was a different figure
it out get down start licking something
women like different things what do
women that you've been dating like
I
want you to tell me what you do with
your tongue
you know you start out slow I think
and uh I don't know stick your dick in
there
yeah that's it all right
um Sam any questions for Dylan no all
right what'd you think about uh that
last guy that was up here you know him I
don't know him but I can relate to the
anxiety you know you just gotta yeah you
know
boom yeah it's scary yeah it's hard
being a man with all our emotions yeah
stuffed up deep inside us and then we
need a finger in the butt oh you're not
an emotional guy
me no I'm completely normal
no I've looked into your eyes dude you
have a soul I think what about my eyes
you have a soul I've seen your soul are
you talking about my Kia Soul
no are you making an Asian joke no no no
I was being like genuine and stuff
thanks look into my eyes all your
friends left dude
this is how this is how the Barbie movie
ends with Ken I'll uh
there he goes oh [__]
to his pink convertible
all right well we got a woman named
Kaylee coming up
Kaylee is that woman still here
the women have left I think the women
that were in there I don't know why they
left maybe it was me yelling at them to
shut the [__] up
that tends to dry up [__] quicker than
anything
is this Kaylee are you Kaylee
you want to be she can be do you want to
identify as a Kaylee
we need a woman look at this guy he's so
lonely up here only you can stop a
school shooting
[Laughter]
Morgan give it up for Morgan she's
coming oh [__] okay
a real life single woman who is polite
at comedy shows
that's a rare find nowadays
hey it's Morgan laughing maniacally this
was just like home wow I've been here
before
90 seconds starting now what's your name
again Dylan Dylan uh how old are you 31.
I can tell I'm just kidding no you look
good you're good thank you 31 year old
you look like me how old are you well
how old do you think I am uh
like 30 no I'm just kidding yeah
yeah almost late I'm actually 57 27
that's my guess 27. 27
.3
do you smoke cigarettes I do not uh come
on I thought I wanted I thought I was up
here with a real man it's like a
cigarette real men killed themselves yes
dude I'll mention codes
[Applause]
I didn't say that don't cancel me
oopsies then you would only have you
know women [__] you know
are you not here for the show earlier
no yeah that was what I was referencing
oh wait what
I thought you were so confused I saw you
uh I saw you on kill Tony
yeah I did that yeah yeah it was really
good
I've been on it yet wait what you
haven't been on there no not yet have
you you haven't got pulled from the
bucket of Destiny no not yet not yet
fingers crossed yeah
up my ass fingers crossed yeah
her tiny joke book
time yeah
they both love comedy
there's nothing that gets women wet like
comedy yeah so uh you said all men
should kill themselves
how serious were you about that
yeah
oh comment you say you hate but you're
as sexist as any man I know well I like
her head and I dump them head and dump
them yes
let's play
Dylan
how do you feel about this
dump them as well what what do you use
women for head and dump them as well
no I got attached and [__] oh like a
[__] maybe you should just
excuse me more women talking
let's try to be a little respectful guys
yourselves I know Joe Rogan yeah
have you guys signed up are any of you
guys signed up for the show are you guys
just talking when you're not on stage
you guys want to talk on stage
do you want the floor
all right what you guys uh do you guys
not like Morgan's sexism because I agree
with you I think it's out of line
that need to be protected there's a
serial killer killing men right now
because it's just me talk like you
um you said that she looked 27 what part
not really what made you say 27. I was
trying to be a dick for some reason I
don't know it's okay I'm like an [__]
I invite the Dick Energy I'm like oh
yeah you came in the [__]
yeah
woman being uh themselves is inviting
I must be on my period it's called
nagging yeah you were right right
classic [__] boy maneuver I got it I
love it
appearance was really good and then you
looked like yeah I don't know I was
trying to be addicted I was trying to be
sarcastic it didn't really work hey as
long as I got fans out here recognizing
me if you want the autograph I can give
you it
well again uh do you get a lot of guys
like coming up to you just like trying
to hit on you by calling you old yeah
how does that usually work out oh I just
let them die
what does that comes out yeah dude it's
crazy I can't say it right it didn't
happen just like those Dentures come out
oh yeah that numb mouth oh wait you were
talking about the Tea thing right yeah
yeah the Dentures oh yeah yeah I lost my
teeth in nam she's a couple jokes behind
but she's getting there
I'm just a woman I'm sorry
oh no this is a very interesting
this is a very interesting couple
you feel like it's toxic someone's
someone's hitting someone so yeah which
way the cops are getting called for sure
yeah then when the cops get there you're
gonna deny it you're like no I love you
I love him don't take him to jail
I think Morgan would hit Dylan because
Dylan what's uh what's what's been the
most romantic date you've ever been on
besides this one
uh hmm I don't know probably just I
haven't had many dates you look like a
kind of guy that could uh have a good
time just with a hoagie and a beer at a
hockey game just yelling at people
have you ever done that no no I actually
haven't not yet not yet I think that's
in your future hey dude Never Say Never
she's gonna stick your finger up your
butt if you're lucky all right you could
do it up to the knuckle that's it
start getting screaming
man what's that you don't know what a
taint is I'm drawing I'm trolling
what's that
what's the most amount of fingers you
ever put in a guy's butt just one you
never tried to get ambitious I do now
that you said it I feel like it's a
challenge in my head who wants it which
two would you do
um probably like
her just like
like [__] just up the [__] the
stinker yeah
[__] on his chest what the [__] is that
if he's lucky for the stinker
now that costs more so how much DM
I don't know what you said DN don't fall
for it
[__] you God's got it I was coming back
she just missed out letters and then
it's like her personality
it is I have it on my necklace
uh Dylan
have you ever dated a juggalo before no
no she repeat me you know what girl uh
who had the most bris uh race bracelets
of all the girls
any bracelet girls I don't think so oh
maybe one who are you [__] mostly
just like single moms no
no like [__] I don't know hippie
chicks kinda hippies chicks nice what
are you saying maybe one bracelet
huh what's your pickup line with hippie
chicks
did you
no I don't know I haven't really had a
um
have you heard about 5G
they disguise them as palm trees all
right man we're killing it with
ourselves yeah let's go we're cracking
ourselves up over here
Morgan what's your craziest conspiracy
theory that you believe in
um [__]
I don't really pay attention to that
[__] oh what do you pay attention to are
you more like TMZ
TMZ no
um uh what do I uh
I like ASMR on tick tock
okay not what you jerk off to
[Laughter]
Doug
IES
conspiracies
you can't pronounce it apparently I
don't know any experiencies is that 23
that she has a conspiracies you like
Hans
uh JFK is fun what about him yeah they
killed him who Sierra CIA oh that was
before you don't remember the CIA
who is that sorry
Dylan what's the uh biggest age
difference between someone you've dated
four and a half years whoa you're going
crazy man
yeah what's like a thing that like the
generational where you notice the
difference
I mean
I don't know maybe she was slightly more
mature but I didn't notice much of a
difference did she break up with you
basically that's really mature
good for her
how tight was her [__] it was good good
just good I yeah it was good drugs
you know like has anyone ever had like
what have you ever been with a [__]
that was too loose yes yeah really you
figure it out it still works so it's not
as you know you just gotta pinch the
bottom yeah
[Applause]
trick you could do with the legs yeah
this is a great day this looks like a
parole officer meeting with his parolee
yeah yeah I'm the officer right yeah
Morgan what's the last thing you
shoplifted
oh God I shoplifted in years I got
arrested for that but no way
um last thing I shoplifted [__] dude
it's been it's been years probably like
trail mix from HEB or something
I was like [__] up I'm like I don't
know you work at a pizza shop and you
steal food and you're still not fat oh
dude yeah I still so much food I'm just
kidding wait till you're 27. I'll kill
myself how'd you steal it
you're a white girl a Mexican [__] well
three percent don't [__] count I
don't know what you're talking about
[__] three percent [__] whoa oh [__]
Morgan how big
how big do you think Dylan's
[__] is not big enough
she's got a big enough for picking up
her trail mix
do you keyster
would you kiss her I don't know what
that is
if you like got pulled over would you
shove like the [__] [__] up your
butthole
hide from Cops
it it what is it is it
a kilo of cocaine what are we talking
here a lot of difference it's like
taking a big [__] apparently it doesn't
even need a car she starts shoving
things in her [__] when a rent a cop
is behind her
they do if I'm lucky what's a rent a cop
what's that that was the memo well Dylan
is there uh anything that uh you could
do with uh take take Morgan out on a
date that you could maybe seal the deal
with her you think
oh no
what would you do where would you go
where where's your go-to do I have to
um
I mean probably a bar
um I'm kidding I'm not
what what I don't know what
don't think about it too hard she's not
a lady well I was trying to think of
something
she's down if you know what I'm saying
she is uh independent woman with her own
thoughts and feelings
um what's what's the latest uh time that
you respected a woman the what what's
the last time you respected a woman what
does that mean
oh you respect people
yeah but I don't know like have you ever
opened a door or like oh donated a
kidney
I've opened the door I don't know
probably a long time
no kid no uh not yet
not yet Never Say Never [__] maybe yeah
I heard two kidneys go for like 250 000.
I don't know how true that is but if
you've given away kidneys I mean I got a
cooler up something up figured out and I
I think I want it this
think let me know you know not that
decision a little harder
well thank you guys for being on the
show hopefully this was a better date
than your first one with the guy that
was oh my God boring [__] Mormon ass
[__]
is much more exciting and fun yeah you
were way more better than my first
[__] day [__] thanks
okay that was the show thank you guys so
much for coming out Sam anything you
want to say to the wonderful people no
it did feel like after they left
everyone got put in time out though like
the energy yeah is that true everybody
else feel that everyone was like am I
next they were like oh [__] Easter keys
to the drugs all right just don't talk
at full volume in the middle of the show
yeah but uh that was a show thank you
guys so much for coming out we watched
people [__]
hell yeah that was a show thank you
[Applause]
[Music]